this coming week is the 100th
anniversary of an American treasure
Zion National Park was established on
November 19th 1919
today Zion is more popular than ever and
a new film will be released this Tuesday
to celebrate the parks epic trails
climbs and River walks it is hard to
find a more stunning place on earth than
Zion we were lucky enough to find two
perfect guides we are headed out here to
canyon overlook looking down pine creek
canyon our trip to zion began at the
parks all inspiring canyon overlook and
you've got nine layers of geology you
are looking at more than 250 million
years of history from top to bottom when
you come through the entrance of the
canyon it's just like wow what planet
are we on here they've got one yeah
these rocks have given Jeremy Collins
both his obsession and his profession
he's among the world's most recognized
at free climbing and landscape sketching
well I started drawing the same time you
did in kindergarten and just never
stopped and it's gone on to define my
whole career that's how I do my
storytelling
Collins has traveled the world to climb
mountains from China to Venezuela and
the Arctic Circle but always returns
design you spend enough time in a place
and it becomes home and that's ayan for
me and now stars in a new documentary
celebrating the parks Centennial like
the layers of rock here there's layers
of stories about Zion you get lost
sometimes yeah now you go into the zone
the world disappears for a minute and I
think anyone wants that experience these
days more than four million visitors
come to Zion every year looking for some
version of the same experience they
follow Zions scenic drive hike to
angel's landing and walk the narrows
I'll spend time working in the Visitor
Center maybe sometime Roofing Trails
Park Ranger Darci McKinley Lester
started walking us to her favorite spots
the Emerald Pools you just got to be
careful of spines along the way we found
a snack all you got to do is prickly
pear cut it split it open and then once
you get the skin peeled off you've got
this beautiful fruit on the inside there
reminds me of pomegranate and strawberry
yeah that's more yeah I do this is my
favorite spot right up here feel
sometimes the mule deer walking through
here because it's green year-round so
they can always find food it's kind of a
little sanctuary for everything that's
here but that's the thing about Zion
you've got waterfalls and desert mm-hmm
yep you have these two ecosystems
meeting up and so you can also look up
or look out and you can see more of the
desert but right here you're in that
little oasis of water that you don't
always find in a desert landscape that
water from the Virgin River carved Zions
epic Canyon but this area wasn't well
known until 1904 when this painting was
featured at the World's Fair in st.
Louis it was so stunning the story was
many didn't believe it was real in the
1920s the Union Pacific Railroad
launched a very successful campaign to
market the park
featuring coeds dressed in the latest
fashionable hiking gear pictures were
published as far away as London a tunnel
that allowed far more to access the park
was completed in 1930 a shuttle and tram
system was introduced in 2001 there is
no Tran the goes to the places Jeremy
Collins prefers I'm gonna follow your
route this thing get pretty mean in the
spring I would imagine doing this when
it's rushing oh yeah grabbing it your
knees still cold yes it is he took us to
the climbing wall called moonlight
buttress watch out for this yucca here
oh yeah it looks mean looking for a
particular challenge like is it
something that I can free climb for me I
want I'm a free climber like I like to
use my hands and feet not my gear when
climbing is your passion an opportunity
like this can't be passed up although
this one wasn't necessarily Parc
approved dude be careful you just can't
resist huh well if I'm not gonna get the
climb while we're out here least I can
stress you guys out
[Music]
I've had experience climbing in here in
the park when I'm all alone and even
though I felt like I was on fire it was
also a pretty special experience just
having the place to myself
do you like punishing yourself I think
anybody who's climbing cracks has a
little bit of a masochistic bent
[Music]
Zion National Park may be turning 100
but as Collins is happy to tell you it
never gets old I would say if you find a
place you love
keep going back wait five years and come
back you know develop a relationship
with that place because when you have a
relationship with a place or a person
you want to take care of that thing it's
interesting to hear Collins talk about
that you know you don't have Nestle if
they try to visit every single National
Park but if you find one you love go
back again and again because there's so
much to explore and I thank you Jeff
Glor Oh fire there's something about
being in places like that there's a
trust I can't tell you what yeah up five
hikers that that tram left behind
and if you'll say it's dead of night
yeah my daughter said you can't leave
him out there I was like okay if you say
so I love that watching your piece
though I felt calm watching the first
part of it I've been watching Jeremy go
free climbing wasn't parks anxious but
again he can't resist you know Jeff went
up to